maybe the best thing to come out of
sunday was uh the gift that keeps on
giving and that being uh cam newton's
bruh next in the queue harry his bro
reaction to whatever nicu harry was
telling him is just probably the best
gift we got in a long time and it was
one of the best things to come out of
yesterday reason here's what i'll ask
you based off of that just because
coming into the season cam newton was
cam newton for me look at this i mean
this is just you can do so much with
this
man like
man
you come on bro it's like
is anybody by the way have we gotten to
the bottom of what nikhil harry said yet
i don't know if we know this and i need
to know what he said to make him react
that way but anyway here's what i'll get
to with you norah
coming into the season camden was my
most interesting man in the nfl i had a
feeling he would ball out he's doing it
so far
is it a stretch for me to say we all
know how
you know popular was to to hate on the
patriots for obvious reasons for the
last 20 years has cam newton kind of
sort of made it cool to pull for the
pets
i love that you're asking me this cool
so we can dissect cool a little bit
right but he's made them likeable
i think there's a lot of people who
don't want to admit that they like the
patriots because they're watching i mean
he's got a thousand watts smile he's
nicknaming everybody there's like
little
little guy and
mini biscuit and all the you know
belichick like dollar dollar bill like
they're so fun it's impossible
brady and gronk were like oh we want to
have fun let's go hang out with can go
wearing bruce aryans look how fun it is
to be in new england right now with cam
thank you norah it's so oh it's
incredible so yeah i i think they're
i think they're right on that precipice
right where there's a lot of people who
are kind of saying to themselves
ooh i gotta look in the mirror and
decide if if i'm willing to do this if
i'm willing to say out loud that i kind
of enjoy watching the patriots and it's
also
the style of football that they're
playing where they can win in all these
different ways and and you know some
days it's through the air some days it's
the ground game with newton running some
days it's like we saw uh what day is it
monday yesterday
um
they had their running backs going so
you kind of never know what you're gonna
get you get the sense that belichick's
having a great time i didn't have a
blast
yeah mike because michael think about it
think about this michael not only were
the patriots as you know
certainly not well liked around the
country and some of just people get
tired and fatigued of the excellence but
it was also to noah's point the way they
went about it right but there was
nothing fun about brady and belichick
but also cam for a lot of people
for a lot of different reasons had
become
unlikable
okay and now you put them together mike
tell me you're not having fun watching
this team together
oh sure sure i'm having fun watching
them dollar dollar bill as nora pointed
out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports